hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers
infinity war is a new trailer filled
with huge reveals lots of our favorite
face is getting mutilated in two old
dudes fighting over fancy gloves now
just let me tire themselves out although
they are really fancy some heroes defend
the universe from space tyrants other
heroes obsessively scrutinized Marvel
trailers for Easter eggs and subtle
clues that you missed the first time
around I'm the first kind of course but
I'll give this Easter Egg stuff a shot
also this video is sponsored by our
friends at Dollar Shave Club stick
around to the end for details about an
exclusive offer that is just for you
guys and for the predictions I'm about
to make spoiler warning I suppose if
them any of these end up being right
let's dive in
the entire time I knew him he only ever
had one call
[Music]
to wipe out half the universe okay we
start with this upside down rotating
shot of Manhattan and this really isn't
a natural image to start on it reminds
me a lot of these spaced bending imagery
of dr. strange now notice that we don't
see that OSes cue ship in this shot
despite seeing and hovering over
Manhattan in all the other shots so I'm
guessing that this rotation is from the
point of view of that cue ship we see in
New York spinning because the ring is
spinning waiting to do something
horrible also recently in black panther
the director used a similar rotating
shot to reflect an outside threat
invading the homeland and taking over
how the world has turned upside down
under this usurper the Russo brothers
may be doing the same thing to show how
fan oohs is about to turn this world
upside down and if you look closely in
the sky you can see a falling object
burning up in the atmosphere I'm
guessing that's Hulk Bruce Banner in
previous trailers we saw Bruce having
crash-landed in the sanctum sanctorum by
the way this detail may be coming from
the Infinity Gauntlet comics where
Silver Surfer crash lands in the sanctum
this shot of Wanda Bruce a war machine
looking at the sky maybe from a separate
sequence in the movie which I'll talk
about when we get to that point so let's
move on he gets all the Infinity stones
[Music]
tell me his name again tennis okay more
shots of New York here you can see that
falling object from before maybe Bruce
reflecting in the sanctum window there
but the big detail here is Gamora who
reminds us that she actually knows a lot
about Thanos she's his adopted daughter
and grew up on his warm nurturing
asteroid now it's interesting that
Gamora says Thanos can wipe out half the
universe with a snap of his fingers snap
of his fingers this is a direct
reference to a panel in the Infinity
Gauntlet comics where if Thanos does
exactly that after acquiring all the
infinity gems he just snaps his fingers
and pouf at the universe dies instantly
while I don't think the nose will have
the stones to do it in this movie
literally you get man seeing that happen
at the end of this movie would be nuts
like what a cliffhanger then again it
sounds like Thanos is 50% heard thinning
will work a little differently in this
movie but more on that later also just
so we're clear I don't think stark and
Gamora are in the same scene
here but lighting the backgrounds are
totally different actually the gamora's
on the Milano with the other Guardians
and Thor while stark is somewhere else
and before I move on dam famous
certainly looks intense with the helmet
armor that we say I'm wearing this
trailer if you look closely in the shot
he only has one Infinity stone at this
point the Power Stone so judging from
that and the fire in the background this
may be taking place on the wreckage of
that as guardianship that we saw at the
end of Thor Ragnarok the scene in which
it appears Loki handed off the tesseract
space stone to him let's move on we got
one advantage
she's coming to us
we have with Danis once so that's what
we use okay after the marvel fanfare we
see Peter Parker surf in the side of his
school bus like sticky shoes keeping
them there without having it use his
hands kid must been walking through an
AMC or something he's slipping on this
old generation spider-man mask so this
he must be taking place before he gets
Starks iron spider armor hey in case you
were wondering his shirt reads lettuce
the taste of sadness I also like the
detail with Peters swinging too low and
skidding across the water it shows he's
still a little clumsy when it comes to
judging the distance of his swings the
st. Peter maybe you pay a bit more
attention in those classes on pendulum
motion next there's start chasing the
rising cue ship and then a rocket
booster our symbols around his feet Minh
fires him off like a missile now we know
that stark now has the bleeding-edge
armor allowing it to a symbol around him
through nanobots in two different forms
and parts in a recent publicity photo
that included four rocket boosters that
came out of his back you could imagine
start using this text to propel himself
through space or in this case I think
he's trying to help Peter whom we know
got stuck clinging to this cue ship as
it suddenly blasted into the atmosphere
we hear Starks voice saying we have what
they nose wants so that's what we'll use
right as we see Doctor Strange with the
time stone and vision with the mind
stone in his head that's interesting
they says this we mean by that Stark
maybe he wants to use the time stone to
like trap Thanos in a time loop the way
strange did with Dormammu
[Music]
or maybe he wants to use the mine stone
- like convert the mines at Thanos's
black order associates the way Loki used
the scepter to turn Hawkeye and dr.
Selvig or maybe starts just proposing to
use these stones as bait to lure Thanos
into a trap where they would have the
upper hand let me know what you think in
the comments below but let's move on
[Music]
let's talk about this plan of yours I
think it's good except it sucks so let
me do the plan and that way it might be
really good Wow okay the heroes arrive
in Wakanda where King T'Challa Ocoee a
an a oh great Captain America Black
Widow Rhodey Falcon banner in the
background you can barely see Scarlet
Witch helping a limping vision now it's
a little hard to tell but it looks like
vision still does have the mine stone in
his forehead there's a faint yellow glow
there maybe the attempts by the black
order to remove it just left him
weakened or they're using a different
version of this scene for the trailer
also small detail here notice the
wakandan guard on the very far right he
awkwardly looks down at his hand and
then he resumed command position it's
almost like Falcon passed by this dude
and give him a high five and then the
guard was like what the hell is this now
Falcon does have a connection to black
panther in the comics it's actually
where he got his wings and Anthony
Mackie has spoken in interviews about
how Sam's arrival to a place like
Wakanda is kind of a bizarre learning
experience for the character next we see
Shuri using her kimono beads to project
a hologram of visions head with a yellow
mind stone highlighted maybe she's
trying to develop a way to detach the
mind stone from his head without killing
him away maybe that they could better
protect both the stone and vision also
visions physiology must really fascinate
Shuri because remember ultron
constructed him out of stolen vibranium
that he got from Klaus so maybe this
moment is her mind opening up to
possibilities for what can be made with
vibranium next there's this wider shot
of the Guardians stepping off their ship
and judging from the background it looks
like it could be nowhere the home of the
collector in the guardians of the galaxy
and the final place of the ether the
reality stone now it's pretty dark and
vacant there at the moment so maybe
Thanos has already arrived there was a
leaked scene that was going around that
showed fan OHS in the collector but in
any of the footage we haven't really
seen they no snap a red stone into his
gauntlet so we'll see how the reality
stem factors in the plot I'm guessing it
was moved somewhere and then there's
this great light-hearted moment with
star Lord stark Drax and spider-man
they're on this planet that we've seen
in these trailers which we now know is
tightening on the comics and in a real
space Titan is a moon of Saturn in this
movie we're not clear if it's the moon
of Saturn or if it's own separate
homeworld but yeah this world was
destroyed after Thanos tried to warn his
people and they refused to listen to him
and that's where
with led Thanos on this quest to save
the universe from itself make sure to
check out my other video that goes into
all the details on thermoses new origin
and how it's different from what we knew
in the comics but when it comes to these
guys I really wanted to see how these
heroes would mix ever since we saw those
actors together in the original behind
the scenes promo it's just great to see
the two front men of their respective
teams butt heads especially when it
leaves stark for once in his life at a
loss for words Wow let's move on
the end is near
okay in this section we move on to this
battle in Wakanda now by the looks of
things the Avengers are splitting up to
fight Thanos on a few different fronts
one group features the lineup we just
saw Iron Man spider-man the guardians
and Doctor Strange fighting Thanos on
Titan another group features cap Black
Panther Black Widow war machine Hulk
Falcon Bucky Scarlet Witch and vision
you know everyone running in that
wakandan marathon fighting the army of
outriders in Wakanda so we see this team
Bravo joining the united armies of
Wakanda as they zip out the paddle
here's a shot of the Hulkbuster armor
with war machine and Falcons soaring
overhead and then afterward we get some
shots of what might be a third grouping
of heroes the war rocket and teenage
group Thor wears his epic cape and uses
his inner god of thunder power which we
know that he has now thor ragnarok to
summon lightning now look closely at
Thor's hand there it kind of looks like
it's clenched as if wrapped around
something now it was confirmed that Thor
will carry a new version of his hammer a
battle axe called storm breaker
so maybe this is another example of the
trailer featuring a non rendered version
which will change in the final cut of
the shot and maybe we'll say that Thor
is holding that hammer and they just
didn't want to show it off yet in the
trailer also in the background of the
shot you can see that big circular
device we saw in the last trailer some
have speculated that it's a solar Forge
so maybe this whole other mission is how
Thor forges and acquires this new storm
breaker let's move on
half of humanity will still exist
okay in this section there's a shot of
the key ship as it crashes into what
looks like the surface of Titan design
an architecture of all these other
structures looks very interesting so I'm
curious to see what those were used for
maybe there were old warships or
something then we move on to some very
interesting shots of Thanos in this
other world with Gamora as a young girl
or a little green hand grabby Papa's
finger this appears to be a flashback to
the day Thanos conquered gomorrah's
homeworld and kidnapped the young girl
to be his adopted daughter you could see
the other members of this conquered race
with green faces watching on as she
leaves with him soldiers holding the mop
our Chitauri soldiers the army Thanos
gave Loki and Avengers it's interesting
to see young Gamora joining Thanos so
willingly leaving her people behind and
again she was just a little kid maybe
her parents compelled her to go along
with danos who might have just taken her
as a ward so that these people couldn't
try to rise up against him in the future
then we here Theo says voice over saying
when I'm done half of humanity will
cease to exist
huh you know in the comics while Thanos
does wipe out half the universe he
doesn't divide earth into a good half
and a badass he just kind of snaps away
whole galaxies at a time so I'm
wondering what he means by this exactly
how will thin us decide which half of
humanity lives and which dies maybe this
insight is something he hopes to gain
with the soulstone so that he can
determine which souls in the universe
are less likely to threaten him oh no
maybe it's kind of like a cerebro for
moral behavior ready to smite to those
enemies like one of those insight
helicarriers in Winter Soldier oh crap I
just make stuff cinematic universes I'm
sorry then we get this shot of Thanos
grabbing and squeezing Thor's head as
Loki watches on beside the Black Order
now it looks like it's taking place on
that as guardianship I talked about
before you can see those dead bodies
that we saw in the last trailer that the
Black Order is Thanos his team they
include Proxima midnight who remember
she threw her spear at cap in the last
trailer evany mah we see more of him
later core me slave and call obsidian
now there's a whole backstory of those
guys that I plan to explain in another
video so keep an eye out for that
Thanos cracks the tesseract in his hand
like a walnut to get the space stone
it's probably so easy for him because
he's already holding the power stone so
like a tesseract it's nothing and now
since we saw Loki handing off that
tesseract at first it seems like Loki
has betrayed Thor and now he's joined
the enemy side but notice how Proxima is
pointing her spirit Loki
such a threatening manner and the way
thinness grabs Thor's head because it
doesn't look like he's squeezing it so
much says he's holding it in place so
I'm an again after Loki hands off the
space stone Bano swell ruthlessly order
his death perhaps to punish him for
failing him losing the mine stone in the
Avengers and maybe Thanos is forcing
Thor to watch his half-brother die and
at this scream that Thor is letting off
isn't a scream in pain it's a scream in
agony it's sad yeah but killing Loki
would really be a powerful way to raise
the stakes immediately and show how
horrible Thanos is and guys there's a
time stone in the cinematic universe
everything can just be reversed
cool yeah let's move on bleep down
as all things should be
I hope they remember you
okay here's some quick shots show the
heroes and Wakanda gearing up followed
by an explosion where thanassis
outriders appear to have breached the
defense dome protecting Wakanda then we
see some more of this battle on Titan
where Doctor Strange is producing these
magical glyphs first star-lord s spring
board on and off of now some suggested
that quill might be wearing dr.
Strange's vaulting boots of vault or top
across these nomads his boots kind of
look like they always do to me but yeah
it would definitely be and everyone's
interests for strange to let them raid
his sanctum sanctorum for all these
crazy magical artifacts to use I mean
it's Thanos we need an all the above
strategy here next we see this really
uncomfortable shot of dr. strange being
tortured by ebony maw who yeah this
looks super terrifying in the comic 70
mah uses these special webs to force
people's secret's out of them and to
control them these spikes might operate
like those webs but honestly they look a
lot more like the sorcerer magic shards
that were used by kycilia sand dr.
strange may be part of Eponine powers
are to use strangest own abilities
against him which would mean Vanus is a
guy who can pretty much neutralize the
most powerful the avengers is also this
shot of the Hulkbuster armor getting
tackled and overrun by outriders now
it's a rumor that Bruce Banner might
actually be the one inside that armor
like maybe banners having trouble
working up his anger to be Hulk himself
so instead he goes inside the Hulkbuster
armor so this would be a great moment
for banner to suddenly get pissed enough
or hope to bust out of this hole Buster
armor next there's this shot of Thanos
saying I hope they remember you now
people online have said that in the
German version of this trailer Thanos
uses the German word for you that's
plural suggesting that famous might be
talking to a group or people here but
the next shot shows just Stark here
looking particularly beaten down notices
armor leading-edge nanobots are totally
brave they're all frozen in place and
like sloppy like the t1000 when the
grenade launcher makes them all gooey
things aren't looking good let's move on
to the next clip
[Music]
okay big moment here Captain America
somehow being strong enough to resist
the Infinity Gauntlet something that
surprises even Thanos look we knew cap
was strong he was the only Avenger
besides Thor who could budge me linear
but cap must have gulped down a ton of
spinach to hold off the Power Stone and
the space stuff Mayday Mayday
hey T cap could be holding his own
infinity stone that we don't know about
also maybe during his time in Wakanda he
consumed that old heart-shaped herb
which some of you online have speculated
is the sole stone in some other form and
that adds up being the case that would
also make T'Challa
similarly resistant to thanasis power by
the way this standoff with a nose is
very reminiscent to the moment in the
comics when cap stands up to the mad
Titan saying as long as one man stands
against youth thinness you'll never be
able to claim victory it's a pretty epic
moment but yeah I'm just hoping that cap
grumbles Adam I can do this all day
cool yeah yeah hoping we'll see let's
move on to this final section
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man okay in this last little bit
Peter Parker meets dr. strange not
understanding that he actually was a
doctor named strange this kind of calls
back that great joke and the Doctor
Strange movie when Kai silliest
misunderstands a sorcerer supreme Spain
with the doctor it's strange
baby watch a judge and then some crazy
action were spider-man swings and
squeezes through falling debris that's
amazing amazing amazing ok a question
for you guys which adventure do you
think will be the most effective against
Thanos like after watching this trailer
cap definitely looks like it can hold
his own but I'm curious to see what
black panther can do to them mad Titan
comment down below to let me know your
thoughts or tweet me directly at us and
follow the new rock stars on Twitter for
updates on our videos now this video was
sponsored by Dollar Shave Club now I may
not be an Avenger but boy I'm in the
club when it comes to face buzz and yeah
I tried to use store-bought razors to
keep this beast in line but there's just
too many options and the babyface that
works behind the desk doesn't know
anything because it's a child so if
you're like me and you're sick of the
nonsense at the store now is the time to
try out Dollar Shave Club for a limited
time color shape Club is basically
giving away there's shower and shave
starter set to new members for only 5
bucks this starter set features their
executive razor in three trial size
versions of their most popular products
that can help you stay so fresh and so
clean
yeah the first box who received their
shave butter their body wash and one
white from Charlie's butt wipes and you
can laugh but you know you need more
than just razors to stay fresh guys that
butter and wipe guys changed my life my
girlfriend actually hugs me now but yeah
you also receive their executive razor
which includes that premium weighty
handle and a focused set of cartridges
and after the first box replacement
cartridges are sent for only a few bucks
a month this offer is exclusively
available at dollarshaveclub.com slash
new rockstars that style of shave club
calm slash new rock stars or click on a
link in the description below and guys
the 40 dollar shave club enables them to
support this channel so you're really
doing yourselves and us a favor by
checking us out and remember to like
this video and subscribe to the rock
stars for breakdowns and theories on
everything related to Avengers infinity
war pretty much any question you got on
this movie we're gonna try to answer it
guys thanks for watching bye
[Applause]
[Music]